hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
among the stoic paradox is that Cicero
is discussing in that that very work of
the same name this is probably the one
that is the most difficult for people to
accept even people who are practicing
stoicism because it is so uncompromising
it you know in the Latin it runs i
qualia as the piccata at recta factor
that it means wrong actions or you know
literally sins are equal and so are
everything that is done rightly so good
things and bad things in the sense of
actions choices virtues and vices these
are all equal to each other they're
either on the bad side or they're on the
good side and degrees or magnitude
doesn't really matter insofar as it has
to do with their goodness or badness
their wrongness and rightness so this is
quite a difficult proposition to accept
this road does provide some arguments
for it which will shortly take a look at
these are not necessarily conclusive in
the sense that everybody will be
persuaded by them but let's take a look
at what the argument actually are so he
tells us that good and bad actions are
measured by virtues and vices
specifically he begins by saying this is
in paradox three transgressions are not
to be measured by their results by the
the event of what happens right but
rather by the vices of the person who is
engaging in them and likewise with with
virtues so this is assuming that there
is you know vices in the person who is
doing wrong or a vice some sort of
defect right and that there is a virtue
you in somebody who is good and he says
that it does not make a difference a
relevant difference it doesn't mean that
we can't make distinctions but there is
no relevant difference based on the
importance of the situation you know he
says there's no mayest and meanness
greater and lesser that that matters
here there is a greater and lesser but
it just doesn't matter in the fact that
we are doing the wrong thing and the
effects are the consequences themselves
well they do exist are not relevant to
determining whether this is
fundamentally good or bad he provides
some very interesting examples here he
says if you capsize the ship that you
are steering with a cargo of gold
bullion or a cargo of chaff it doesn't
really make any difference it makes it
make difference in the result right
somebody is out a lot of money whereas
somebody just lost some some chaff but
it's an equal mistake so as far as the
Stoics are concerned the one person is
just as culpable as is the other here's
another example passion has made a slip
in the case of a woman of no position in
this case resentment extends to fewer
persons that if it had played the wanton
with some maiden who is a lady of high
birth right so we could transpose this
to the present right somebody is in a
relationship with with somebody else and
there's not a lot of you know stakes in
it but they do cheat on them right
because they're motivated by desire
now imagine somebody who is in a
marriage with children and there's all
sorts of you know family connections
going on and there are political
implications to this and they decide to
screw around right it's just as bad in
either case so there is no well it's
just a small thing the small things
Cicero is saying for the Stoics
or just as much as the big things do as
far as doing them wrong but likewise as
far as doing them right as well there is
an interesting example a little bit
later on where he says somebody might
object whether a man murders his father
or a slave don't you see any difference
there and Cicero says well here's what
the fundamental difference is killing
the slave is only doing one thing wrong
killing your father is actually doing
several different things wrong and so
it's not that the killing itself as far
as killing a person is you know better
or worse in one case or the other but
there's additional heaped on wrong
actions now coming back to this Cicero
makes a lot of this argument depend on
his assertion that virtues are equal to
each other and that because of this
vices are as well he'll make several
different cases for this one of these is
really interesting says nobody can be
more virtuous than the person who
actually has virtue so nobody can be
braver than the brave person nobody can
be more prudent than the prudent person
nobody can be just err than the just
person and and so on so this seems to
deny there being any degrees or
development of virtues it's like an on
switch you either have virtue or you
don't have it as a matter of fact it
even seems to go so far as to say if you
if you don't have virtue if you switch
the switch backwards you have Vikes
instead right and he says that virtue is
displayed in greater and lesser things
greater and lesser not from the
perspective of the virtue or whether the
Act is right or wrong but in terms of
other things so he has an example if we
can trust somebody with $10 if we're
making this contemporary then we can
trust them you know with running a bank
if that's not the case if they're going
to be trustworthy in terms of $10 but
in terms of running the bank they're not
trustworthy they do not have a virtue
then they are actually vicious they have
a vice for example that of greed so
there are other cases that we can we can
look at that are similar to this right
and he talks about virtue in several
different ways that are I think quite
important here
he says virtue in harmony with reason
and unbroken constancy is one nothing
can be added to it to make it virtue in
a greater degree nothing can be taken
away from it and yet the root name of
virtue be left to it if we start
qualifying virtue what we're doing is
we're saying well it's not really virtue
you either possess virtue and its
entirety or you don't possess it is what
he's saying here this is a very
difficult proposition I think for many
to accept now he also makes the case
that vices are going to be similarly
equal to each other so he says it
follows that vices are also equal Y
because vices are correctly called
deformities of the mind provi tastes
onam a right so insofar as vices are
water you know corrupted what are
perverted what are turned aside what are
the opposite of virtue because virtues
are equal vices are going to be equal so
you there's no such thing as saying well
I'm just a little cowardly you're
cowardly there's no such thing as saying
well I'm a little imprudent you're
imprudent and likewise this would seem
to extend you know from situation to
situation a situation
Cicero would not say you are imprudent
with respect to gambling but in
everything else you're prudent if you're
imprudent with respect to one thing it
seems like you have to be imprudent with
respect to all of them now since as he
says right actions equally dry
from the virtues this means that right
actions are also similarly equal to each
other and wrong actions are similarly
equal to each other so he has a few
other interesting discussions a little
bit further on he says in the conduct of
life we ought not consider what penalty
belongs to each transgression but how
much is permitted to each person we
ought to deem whatever is wrong a crime
whatever is not permitted a sin and he
says even in the smallest things yes now
why in as much as we are not able to
impose regulation on things but are able
to regulate our mind he gives an example
of an actor you in here you have to
think of a stage and plaiting you know
not not an actor in a television show
where you can do multiple takes or
anything like that
if an actor screws up even a little bit
Cicero says they've screwed up and it
doesn't matter whether they screwed up
in such a way to knock the whole set
down or not they screwed up and that's
what really matters and they have
control over that he says I will not
listen to a poet when he transgresses in
trifles am I to listen to a citizen when
he measures off on his fingers his
transgressions in the intercourse of
life if they appear smaller in size they
appear so they appear less in gravity
and Cicero says that's a mistaken point
of view how can they appear smaller in
size when every transgression caused by
the dislocation of what he calls system
and order translated here actually Tran
is what it's translating here is Roxio
reason and order or order or de neige or
dou how can that make it better or worse
so the whole impact of this is that
either what you're doing is wrong and in
that case it is just as wrong as any
other wrong that anybody else is doing
or it's right
and in that case it's just as right now
this does leave a lot of questions open
like well isn't there anything in
between or well how do you get from one
to the other or you know our virtues in
some respects more right or good than
the actions that come from them
Cicero does not address that here but
those are worth keeping in mind as you
can consider the starkness of this
doctrine
you